[Music]
as promised we are about to start so
please take your drinks please take your
seats there will be standing area close
to the spiral staircase over there both
behind it you can actually see through
it quite okay you don't see through the
shelves there though uh but there is
plenty of available seatings here still
so please head over this way if you want
to be comfortable for the next hour or
so also now would be a great time to
turn off your
devices please do so and I will usually
always continue talking about something
else after making that announcement
because that way you can do it kind of
you know like secretly so it doesn't you
know it's not obvious um
but I'm very excited to introduce to you
uh our this evening's program but before
that I would like to extend our thanks
to long now members and our sponsors who
make our work
possible the talk will uh talk in the
Q&A will last for approximately an hour
after which you are more than welcome to
continue the conversation over here um
and uh there will also be books in the
back um and it gives me great pleasure
to introduce to tonight's uh speaker
Abby Smith
Ramsey uh Abby is a writer and historian
focused on the creation preservation and
use of the cultural record in all media
she has worked with the Library of
Congress and the National Science
Foundation taught at Harvard and John's
Hopkins University and she's currently
the board chair of the center for
advanced study in the behavioral
sciences in Stanford uh short casbas who
are also our partners in bringing you
this talk tonight yes shout out to
caspas Abby's most recent book out just
last month um is called memory edited
Taking Liberties with history and copies
of that book are available at the back
of the room after the talk AB will be
joined here for Q&A um with by Rick
prelinger Rick is a an archivist a
filmmaker and um also a professor uh at
the University of California Santa Cruz
Rick and Megan prelinger co-founded the
prelinger library which is a publicly
available collection of historical
periodicals books ephemera and other
documents and Rick is also the founder
of prelinger archives which focuses on
moving
images so now let's continue that
Applause and welcome Abby Smith Ramsey
thank
[Music]
you thank you very much it's nice of you
to show up on such a miserable Rainy Day
evening um much as we need the rain it's
not well timed for an event like this at
least from my perspective um I want to
welcome you all um I'm so happy to be
here at long now tonight we're going to
have a conversation about the past and
the future and I want to ask the
question which one comes first does the
future really arise from the past or is
it more true to say that what we think
of as a past arises from how we imagine
the future I don't think it's a very
easy question to answer although it may
seem that way and I telling you we're
not going to be talking about Quantum
Theory although at another scale scale
of
existence well I wouldn't be competent
to talk about it anyway um but we are
talking about the ways that people
conceive of how people feel the passage
of time especially in times of Crisis
which this
is and how controlling images of the
past can be manipulated to control
people's future but what about this
particular moment what will this
particular moment look like in
retrospect in 40 or 50 years what do we
know about this moment which will be
totally inaccessible to people in the
future and what do people in the future
know that we cannot know I think the
answer to that is pretty simple they
know how this will all turn
out I mean I mentioned this um I just
want you to be aware that one of the
great flaws about talking about the past
is that it seems all too obvious that
things turned out the way they had to
turn out however if we were to look back
at this moment in 50 years and and see
how it turned out we might well be
completely shocked at how it turned out
so I want to keep that in mind also keep
in mind that nobody in the past had any
more certainty about how things were
going to go than we do in the future in
the present so I say let's have
compassion for people in the past that
for example they didn't all the wonder
they didn't know all the wonderful
things and behave in The Virtuous ways
that we now
do um first before begin though I want
to take a poll of people in the room how
many of you think that the country is
going in the right
direction whoa I'm glad to see one hand
uh how many of you know feel that things
are going in the wrong
direction for people who can't see the
audience that's a vast majority to say
the least and here's the bonus question
how many of you know how it's all going
to turn
out
so in any event I'm glad that we don't
have any aliens from the
future I talk about this crisis because
it's really an identity crisis for this
country acute polarization that we
suffer from now is a symptom but it's
not the cause of this crisis it's really
an identity crisis and I don't mean this
in the angsty teenage sense and I don't
mean identity politics either I mean in
the most fundamental sense we cannot
agree on who we are we don't really know
who we
are so whose America are we really
talking about Ming making great
again and when was that time when the
country was truly great I think we all
have a different opinion about that and
some think that it never has been great
not their America in any in any
event you know this political slogan in
evokes something that historians are
very familiar with a which we refer to
as a
Nostalgia of Utopia or utopian Nostalgia
that is a longing for a past that
probably never really existed but holds
a very strong grip on our
imagination this political slogan evokes
some some time that was really great and
it was born of a fear of the
future and I can see why people are
afraid of the
future but the slogan itself allows
people to imagine things that they
wouldn't otherwise it gives them
sanction to imagine that there really
was a time that was great I should say
in the interest of fairness that Obama's
slogan was equally provocative and
hopeful his slogan yes we can also was
talking about a future that many people
were afraid of and meant to give
confidence but you can bet that it is
not the same future that people have in
mind so to paraphrase the Talking Heads
how did we get
here it's almost instinctive that when
we end up in a place we didn't expect
such as this place we have to look in
the rearview mirror to figure out where
we took the wrong
turn today when we search the past for
answers unfortunately we stumble into
the Bramble Butch Butch of the of the
history Wars as a nation we simply
cannot sort out what our past is did we
originate in
1776 which was the beginning of the
Great exper expent in Democratic
self-governments or did the present day
America originate in
1619 when Prosperity today has been
bought we realize at the expense of
other people's land other people's labor
and other people's
freedom I would argue that both versions
of this get it completely wrong and fall
into the fallacy of Origins the mistaken
notion that our Origins determine our
ends that is what we call history as
prophecy
history is not prophecy the Trump Merch
this magar red hat signals not a set of
ideological beliefs but loyalty to a man
and membership in the warm embrace of a
tribe such behavior is mirrored equally
on the left to be frank which has its
own slogans its own merch its own tribal
behaviors and which is often called
virtue signaling this polarization has
led to a bizarre loss of touch with
reality the last time I was saw such
departure from reality or to put it
kindly departure from a shared sense of
reality was in
1983 I was living in mos in Leningrad at
the time I want to note that all maps
are courtesy of the David Rumsey map
collection um in very high resolution I
was living in a dormatory and my
roommate was from the closed military
city of vasto which you can see here 11
time zones away from Leningrad and
Moscow the first departure from reality
that was that vladas sto was kept
officially on Moscow time not local
time she came back one day from a trip
to the market a trip that took her hours
incidentally with a prize purchase and
that was a kilo of butter butter was a
scarce commodity even in the
well-provisioned cities such as
Leningrad Moscow and
vlasto she beamed with the pride of
someone who had just won the lottery and
frankly she had every right to gloat she
asked me how often butter was available
in our markets I answered
always I had just read the international
hero Tribune article about farmers in
Wisconsin dumping tons of cheese in
protest for the farm bill but I spared
her that
detail the word always was so far from
what she could even imagine that she had
to take a beat then pulling herself up
in all of her dignis dignified
skepticism she said in a tone somewhere
between pity and condescension that she
understood that naturally I was a
patriot and I love and I had to defend
my motherland but I did not need to
lie when I protested that I wasn't lying
she grew indignant I had just confirmed
to her everything she had ever heard
about
capitalists so what I took away from
that year in Moscow and Leningrad was
less about the subject I was studying
and more my knowledge that in fact those
who can can uh control a population
sense of reality their imagination
really controls them totally it they
control what they can imagine what is
possible and what is not possible in the
world for that woman more than a kilo of
butter in the market every single day
was simply not a possibility that was
Earthly at at
all my experience means and I take it
with me almost every day is that I look
at the present situation from an oblique
angle the better to see what's going on
in this country with In a Different
Light so in 2016 I first learned about
alternate facts I was alarmed what had
happened Trump ran in 2000 he talked
about running in 2004 he campaigned
without declaring officially in 2012 how
many people predicted that he was going
to live sorry live um when in
2016 I mean he told those same
outrageous I all the time although they
got more robust over over the ages what
I was really shocked by was the
eagerness with which our fellow citizens
and they are our our fellow citizens
believed them to be true or wanted them
to be true or frankly just needed them
to be
true why is that well we'll get to this
but first I want to um show you uh the
kinds of everyday hacking hijacking of
history that the Soviets did which may
be instructive on the extreme right is
Nikolai yof the man who ran the nkvd
which was this of the predecessor of the
k um sorry KGB he was the man
responsible for conducting Infamous
purges of the
1930s oops he fell victim to the purges
himself so after he fell victim to the
purges there was a new version of the
future it was a future in which jof was
not Stalin's trusted comrade and frankly
had never been I want to tell you that
falsifying evidence is as old as
evidence
itself so here today gone
tomorrow am I saying to you that we are
at risk of doing something like this in
this
country I mean personally I wouldn't
have thought that this brace and
manipulation of facts was
possible um before now because after all
we live in the land of freedom of
expression and and the Press we're all
Forward Motion we um are all progress
civic education from the early 19th
century which is when this timeline was
done by the great female educator will
will um sorry Emma Willard um inculcated
in us as Citizens that we were leaders
in the virtues of freedom and equality
at this point Americans were busy
defining who they were and where they
fit into the world this map told them
that they could look back and see that
their own place in history was extremely
short and abbreviated and they wanted to
become
therefore um the Vanguard of the
future but so did these men want to
become the Vanguard of the future here
you see Lennon and trosky in 1920 in
Moscow I have a big blue arrow pointing
to trosky because somehow something
magical is going to happen to
him marks and Engel said in the
Communist Manifesto Like Us in communist
Society the present dominates the past
and I'd say in truth it is the past that
more or less determines the the present
in most cases but in our society it is
always the present that determines the
past the Russians took certain liberties
with history to bring it into a line
with with Marxist theory and here you
can see that when trosky was expelled
from the party in
1927 he also was lost to history or at
least he became an alternate fact in
alternate history
even before Pho Photoshop was invented
it was always easy to bring the past
into alignment with the present you know
I'm sure many of you have heard the joke
that Soviets and I think Russians
probably still tell which is the future
is certain it's the past that's always
changing the business of revising
history is very active these days and
not just in Russia not just in China but
also in this country as
well I want to share something with you
you um from the Memoirs of this
spectacular woman nades deam here she
was in 1922 when she was 23 years old
and married to the poet o mam who would
be um who would perish in the um in the
gulag shortly after this time she
happened to be staying in the family of
the family home of Victor schi who many
of you may know is the great Russian
literary critic here she's describing
schow's um teenage daughter varia and
here I'm quoting from the Memoirs she
showed us her school textbooks where the
portraits of party leaders had thick
pieces of paper pasted over them as one
by one they fell into disgrace this the
children had to do on instructions from
their
teacher varya said how much she would
like to cover up commissar Nikolai soska
I mean after all we're going to have to
sooner or later why not now but she had
to wait for instructions at the same
time the editors of encyclopedias and
reference works were sending subscribers
most such Works were actually so sold
through subscription at that time a list
of articles that had to be pasted over
or cut out with every new arrest people
went through their books and burned the
books of disgraced leaders in their
stoves witer Heating in the new
apartments which had central heating
instead of stoves forbidden books
personal Diaries corresponden and other
so-called sub of literature had to be
cut into tiny little pieces with
scissors and thrown down the toilet as
she said people were kept very busy and
this will explain Soviet Plumbing to
you so I say props to the teenage girl
who had a sense of humor about it that
said she was helpless to do anything
except cultivate a sense of humor about
it you know memory is a remarkable thing
and the way it can be manipulated for
good and for ill is quite remarkable
because of its inherent flexibility what
you see here is a a cell from the
hippocampus which is the main organ of
memory in the human mind actually in all
organs Minds you see 's done a little
imitation of it here very elegant
thankfully our nervous system is
designed to be flexible so that it can
learn about the world and modify its
understanding of the world you see all
the time we're learning we have a little
model of the world in our brains which
actually predicts what we're going to
see so that when something is different
we notice it right away it's a very
efficient system of staying alert to
threats um but and so brain scientists
these days actually refer to the brain
as a prediction
machine but that also means that the
brain to be efficient has to throw away
a lot of information it judges to be
irrelevant and unimportant and thus I
say that for a good memory forgetting is
a feature it's not a bug in short memory
is the raw material of our ourselves as
individuals and as members of society it
comprises our identity in effect to
hijack history is tan amount to identity
theft and it is to my mind a political
crime whoever commits
it you know it's remarkable but nesa mam
lived well into her 80s here she's seen
she's 80 years old still is fetching as
ever and still smoking
cigarettes I don't know what her magic
was except this she was determined to
survive she was determined to survive
remember and write down everything not
just her husband's poetry which couldn't
be written down in her lifetime but also
everything and to teach us lessons to
the extent that she could although she
wasn't very optimistic about anybody
learning anything from
history let me uh just again quote from
her memoirs which I think is really
touching for us these days the capacity
of memory both Collective and individual
to gloss over to improve on or distort
the facts is particularly evident at
periods when the foundations of society
are
collapsing these disorders to which
memory is prey the tendency to embellish
or suppress awkward detail the need to
vindicate oneself show how dangerous it
is to rely on one's own conviction of
being right since this is all too often
based on false criteria our main task is
instead Define true criteria there's
also the problem that while distorting
our Recollections and thus hindering a
proper appreciation of individual or
historical experience memory is at the
very core of our Humanity it is all that
we
have mam incidentally survived because
she was a woman women were not
recognized as political agents in the
Soviet Union and I dare say perhaps in
Russia as well
and certainly in most parts of the world
women could be used as Weapons against
men as as emotional blackmail but they
had no
agency so a little confession this is
not a portrait of nadam of course is a
painting by the great painter kazimir
malevich who I think properly depicts
what this kind of world look like that
there were people who were made as as
great prototypes um in this case a woman
farmer but featureless she was just part
of a mass and absolutely featureless
because in fact she had no
memory as mom says the first task is to
recovery memory in all of its complexity
the good the bad the ugly and the
Beautiful and to do that we must start
with the facts of the case those are
often very hard to find even in
libraries and archives and museums
especially if archives and museums are
collected in such a way to slant
information to to record only that part
of history that we like that we agree
with or we think it's going to be
indictment of our enemy it's very easy
to plant information to to be read later
in a way that's
distorted so a special ple of libraries
and archives which as you know are just
critical in this
moment you know I can't go into all the
complexities of why and how the Russian
state has decided to close its memory to
Outlaw its civilian Cadre of um
historians and to close the archives to
most
people but a major undertaking of
Putin's regime is to rebuild the Russian
State um as a state that transcends
history in many ways or is old and
sacred he does this through the
aggressive rewriting of History texts
you can see this happening in China as
well it's happening in the United States
on both the left and the
right
but I think that we know need to go far
deeper than just getting the facts of
the case correct or or making sure that
our history textbooks align with the
facts I think we have to move beyond the
model of history as the march of
progress I think that's the main reason
we were so unwilling or unable to cope
with the Cascade of catastrophes that we
experienced in the last three decades so
what's happened to us in the last three
decades well there was WI 2K which we
kind of skated past then there was 911
which few people seem to anticipate
including our security agents then there
was a 2008 financial crisis which was
staring Us in the face but nobody seemed
to see then we were kind of relieved
when Obama was elected and then shocked
that Trump was was following him then
there was Co 19 then there was January
6th and then there was Ukraine and
unfortunately this weekend we have the
Middle East more Slaughter more
senseless death
and the reason that Americans have been
caught backf footed so many times
psychologically is because we're simply
not prepared to know how to deal with
catastrophes like this if everything is
all Forward
Motion I I'll note that we P we face
this dilemma over and over again in our
history and apparently we don't
recognize how familiar that is I'm
thinking in particular now about the
innovation of of artificial intelligence
the promise and the threat before that
there was the promise and the threat of
social media which was still behind
dealing with and before that there was
the promise and the threat of the of the
internet itself still hard to catch up
with that and some of us remember the
promise in the threat of TV which seems
to have abated only because TV itself
has fallen by the wayside uh due to
other
media there seems to be a reflex in the
American psyche that if we hand people
the most appropriate and upto-date tools
that they will always bring out the very
best in people and only that so why do
we so tenaciously cling to our belief in
our own innocence this is a point that
was made very well by one of the fellows
former fellows at casbas Jennifer
Richardson who wrote a wonderful essay
in the Atlantic Monthly about why it is
that Americans particularly white
Americans are surprised every time
there's a seeming setback in the racial
progress in fact it depends upon your
point of view we actually need to
believe that in order that we can move
on but it's not in fact true we can't
just be you know free riters on
progress you know as One True Believer
in progress said it's difficult to
predict the extent of self-government
that the that the man of the future may
reach or the heights to which he may
carry his technique social construction
and psychophysical self-education will
become you know two aspects of one in
the same process all the Arts literature
drama painting music and architecture
all will lend this precious beautiful
form man will become immeasurably
stronger wiser and subtler his body will
become more harmonized his movements
more rhythmic and his voice more
musical so does anyone recogniz this
voice it was the voice of
Trotsky in case you didn't realize it
that Marxism Springs from the exact same
belief in the almost Limitless
perfectability of humans and doubt as we
are with reason cultivated through
education and the ultimate product of
which is technological that is material
progress Marx believed in the ultimate
liberation of humankind from the
constraints of nature the Bolsheviks
simply wanted to speed up the process
but it's not a dream that is unknown in
this country as
well so if we don't believe in this
March of progress um because we believe
in deep time now and here again there's
this fantastic new map of the timeline
of History done um I don't know 2008
yeah um it's still all upwards and
forward motion um you know we still
believe that it's all
progress we have very different views of
human nature now than did the founders
of our Republic or marks and Engles the
pillars of their enlightened vision of
self-government was reason we have to
accept the cognitive science not to
mention darwinian evidence throws shade
on just how objective human rationality
can be Scholars such as Daniel Conan
also a casbas fellow and Amos tersi have
sh shown that reason is often just a
post Haw justification for decisions we
make through older non-rational parts of
our brain the ones that really are
Geared for our survival that are tied
into our emotional um instincts and to
our amydala
furthermore Enlightenment views of the
compatibility of Liberty and equality I
can't say have held up all that well in
a nation as diverse not to mention
polarized as ours we have just to look
at the Supreme Court's docket to see
that one one person's Liberty can become
an impin on someone else's I urge all of
us who think that democrac democracy is
worth saving and fighting for to think
about the need to reinvent it for the
Contemporary world we can't just rely on
Old views of human nature and old views
of how history unwinds
itself so how exactly should we be doing
long-term thinking
now um first I know that we need to
acknowledge the past without believing
that it is a tale of Destiny we cannot
conflate the past with the future
history is not prophetic nor it's
history a moving sidewalk we don't just
step on time and it moves along whether
we hurry along or not it will end up
taking us forward and in
progress I will say that the past is
critically important as a Point of
Departure but probably nothing else it
doesn't for foretell the future it is
the place from which we begin the rest
is a matter of contingency and chance
and if this map even though it was done
in 1849 10 years before the origin of
the species was published if this map
doesn't foretell just how complicated
and fortuitous and history can be then
how many strands are intertwined and and
how say someone can come along in one
line The Thin Line at the top is that
goes all the way across is Alexander the
Great glorious conquered much territory
but didn't last long and the Roman
Empire which had had many tributaries
which have died out and sometimes gone
into very interesting rivlets in strange
places were presented therefore with
endless choices to be made without fully
understanding any of their consequences
and the faster we feel the the pace of
time the more urgent we feel the need to
make decisions without considering the
consequences and again I urge that now
particularly at this moment we step back
and not just reach for ready solutions
to the problems that we face and
certainly not reach for Comfort when
there is little Comfort to be had except
through well assuring ourselves of
things that we can assure ourselves
about so this is why my my message
really is that in the absence of this
certainty the one thing that we need to
be crystal clear about is the moral
foundations of our
decision and that's not very
easy so what do we do with history what
do we do do with the past Socrates
reputedly said reputedly said that an
unexamined life is not worth living I
don't know I mean I know plenty of
people who don't examine their lives and
seem to be very
happy but I but I will say categorically
that the unexamined past is
dangerous so what are we supposed to do
with the statues of say Confederate um
generals and other public art that
reflects views that we now hold to be
anathema are we supposed to just destroy
them destroy evidence they existed
should we take a hint from the Soviet
from the Russians who have actually
rounded up some of these statues and
made a park out of them the Russians
love Parks um and this is outside of
Moscow and there's evidence of the past
there's also evidence of revulsion
against that past you'll notice that
Stalin is missing his big nose you know
the defamed statues the deface statues
are here so people can see both what was
believed and also how people refuse to
believe
it you know I talk about knowing the
truth um but how are we supposed to
really know the truth if as mom says we
should always question whether we are
right or
not how can we even talk about what we
think is real when nowadays reality is
kind of all triggers all the way down I
suggest that we keep in mind the words
of this man chadf who had the
distinction of being the first Russian
to be called insane because of his
political views hence the name of his um
last missive the appal loia of a
Madman he said that love of the
Fatherland is certainly a very beautiful
thing but there is something better than
that it was it is the love of
Truth so how do we know the truth well
we test it we test it by talking to
people that we completely disagree with
here some of you may recognize this
debate that was held in 65 between James
Baldwin and William F Buckley um you can
see how old it is you could you should
definitely look at it if you haven't
seen it it's available on YouTube and
all of its grainy Glory it's spectacular
in fact it's harrowing especially from
this
perspective so just as there is tension
as I say between freedom and equality
there's also tension between the
production of truth and the production
of national identity this is inevitable
in a country like our Wars and it should
be frankly to me the fact that we're
fighting over history is a very good
thing there are plenty of countries in
which we are not allowed to fight about
history this to me is what democracy
looks like this is outside the Supreme
Court after the do's decision you'll see
women of about the same age some of whom
are elated and some of whom are in
despair I think it is a category mistake
to see the do's decision as a step
backwards
because history doesn't move backwards
it only moves forward or moves along
just as it is a mistake to see that
Trump's election was
regression it it actually was just the
next stage in an ongoing struggle we
have we didn't solve the problem of
racism by electing a black man send
sending the decision about how to
adjudicate the rights of the born and
the rights of The Unborn back to the
states is a in the next stage of
Engagement it's another chance for us to
work out the differences in a way that
we have not been able to as long as we
were fighting about about um aie
Wade so because I really want to be able
to talk with you and hear your questions
and talk with Rick my grand Inquisitor
let me close on this note no no I I love
the grand Inquisitor he's one of my
favorite characters in fiction um let me
close by saying that long-term thinking
requires radically new temporal framing
not a March of progress not the end of
History you know we live in interesting
times we don't know how things will turn
out but pay attention because if we
don't pay attention and if we don't
participate other people will decide for
us thank
you
I always love talking about time with
this
crowd I really appreciate its
length thank you Abby um I'd really you
know I'd like to tell all of you that
this is a very rich book and that you've
um you've only been able to present a
few of its facets but this book is about
literature it's about art it's about
truth and contested Truth uh it's about
uh uh uh
presentism uh you know a a funny force
in history um there's a lot there and I
urge you to uh to to spend some time
with it um and I'd actually like to talk
a littleit about the truth to begin um
you state in the book that civil society
and civility itself begins and ends with
a shared acknowledgment of the truth
that sounds pretty idealistic now
doesn't it and earlier in the book you
state and I love this quote uh
historical truth is antithetical to
narrative
satisfaction um this runs counter to the
incessantly repeated cliches about
storytelling where we hear that stories
make us human and that narratives help
us create uh patterns and meaning you're
not saying that you're saying that
narrative satisfaction takes us away
from Truth where does storytelling take
the wrong Fork where do good stories end
and bad ones begin well I will say that
if you tell history as a as a narrative
you have to adhere to the rules that
Frank Cod mentioned in one of his books
which is a narrative to be satisfying
has to have a beginning a middle and an
end and that the end has to harmonize
with the beginning you can mess up the M
the middle as much as you want and again
I don't think there are endings in
history I think everything keeps moving
forward and I think the most productive
way of thinking about it one which
actually is liberating is that what
happened in the past is a place of
departure it is not the end I do think
that as people are claiming space for
their own identity um in days in
nowadays they mistakenly refer to my
story telling my story and that means to
me it connotes that one can shade some
of the things that don't fit in with the
narrative and I always object to the the
the the um roughing out of the bad
details or the good details I mean I
think history is full of the good bad
ugly and the Beautiful so you have to
get all of it or it isn't realistic I
think that in terms of
fiction you can you know really helps to
have a narrative um and that narratives
can tell truths through fiction that are
as profound as history but they're not
to be mistaken for each other I also
find it interesting Rick and maybe you
do too that in the 20th century
certainly in the modern era after the
catastrophe of the first world war there
was a rejection by most artists of the
idea of a narrative that could make
sense of anything in fact they wrote in
an anti-narrative way because the world
had ceased to make any sense that was
their way of telling the truth so it's
interesting to me now that storytelling
has been
revived I'm not sure that it's um good
it's appropriate in every case and I
think history is not a case where we
should be telling
stories yeah and we're seeing a bit of a
backlash there was a great piece by Peru
seagull uh in the New Yorker um against
sort of the tyranny of narrative and I
noticed today in the New York Times
reviewing the the films at the New York
Film Festival that what that writer
found uh remarkable is that the the
films were letting narrative go and
focusing on experience but again
experience is is complicated too um I
I've never been called a grand
Inquisitor but um sorry no that's
awesome I I I I feel like I have a new
job um well he was the one who got the
truth out of Ivan karamazov so yeah yeah
um so look uh what I really am is as an
uncredentialed archist and you are a
historian who for much of your career
has worked with libraries and archives
how have memory institutions taken
broadly served the cause of maintaining
and preserving Collective memory and how
have they fallen short how should memory
institutions adjust in this time of of
what you call Source Amnesia and the
spread of disinformation yeah well I do
find find it um interesting that many
Librarians and archists think that um
that their personal judgment about the
nature of Truth and history um affects
their collecting when I've always
understood at least from an historian's
point of view I want archives and
libraries to be full of authentic
evidence um and I can't imagine a world
in which a historian would make sense of
the of you know the past if there were
only one flavor of things I mean I think
one of the things that people are
noticing and um making actually a big
deal about is that the archives that are
created by the people in power um
actually have these what are called
these absences and so we need to fill
them in well it seems to me that if
people collect according to the
political preferences they have which I
can see in certain libraries then
they're creating their own absences and
I don't really understand how they can
justify that I understand why but I just
think it doesn't serve the profession
let me just give you an example um and
uh in um after the breakup of the Soviet
Union there was a brief period of time
when yelson decided that he was going to
open up the archives it was a way of
discrediting his predecessors communist
predecessors including gorbachov and so
for a brief moment of time the Communist
Party archive was open for example and
um when I was working at the Library of
Congress the librarian of Congress Jim
Billington
persuaded um yelton to open an
exhibition of those materials in
Washington and then they would go to
Moscow where where there would be on
display it included Stalin's party card
but it also included and this I give
verbatim in the book A really atrocious
um directive by Lenin in 1920 to go out
and and so round up a couple of hundred
people and hang them high basically as
an example um and and it's the most
disgusting kind of language um and uh
and yet it was in the archives it was in
the party archives so I was talking to
the Russian archist saying it's
remarkable that all this stuff was kept
she said we kept everything and I said
how did you feel about that and she said
well first of all it was our job and
second of all I always hoped this day
would
come and that really moved me and that's
actually I mean after that incident with
my with my roommate and several other
people like that in Russia I thought
that it was one thing to be an historian
but there but at least one person in the
profession should actually be caring
about the way that the source base is
made and that's why I dedicated my life
to spending so much time with libraries
and
archives and yet you know um people
often ask me uh aren't you worried about
all these films that are getting lost
aren't you worried about everything that
we can't save and I say while we
shouldn't in
intentionally destroy things that loss
is actually formative loss uh a
perceived loss of History suppression
censorship destruction of knowledge
leads to the new histories that have
Emer has led to the new histories that
have emerged in the last 40 or 50 years
loss can be formative in the same way
that archival absences can speak louder
or as loudly as presences true very true
yeah the gaps on the shelves tell their
own story and I I kind of haven't worked
that through with regard to some of the
things you say in your book but I I'd
like to um suppressed histories
uh you know I have a the US moved
towards a racial Reckoning in 2020 or at
the very least it gestured in that
direction suppressed histories moved
closer to the foreground there was a
moment where it seemed that in the in
the conventional press that we were
seeing some sophisticated discussions
about race as a discourse and as a
system of power um but we're now seeing
a disturbing reaction on many levels um
you suggest a shared sense of reality
based on the real as a nation are we
capable of that are we capable of
confronting our history and accepting or
moving towards a shared sense of
reality oh yeah I think we are I mean I
think that we need to commit to it but I
do think that well we have to but I do
think that we're capable of it of course
we're capable of it I don't think
there's now here I'm going out in a limb
but I don't think that there's been an
appropriate call to leadership I think
the people who enter public life
now are are the ones who uh want to
disrupt they want attention and I think
the whole the whole notion of Public
Service except in some areas has been
widely discredited and that's what I
think is the real shame that and of
course what all of us probably agree on
which is we need better education for
people you know grades 1 through 12 to
teach people how the government works I
mean I there's no it's no surprise that
people of a certain under a certain age
you know that have never seen Congress
pass a budget for example um all 12
bills um or seen people working across
the aisle have they have no reason to
think the government can accomplish
something so why would they go into
public service and I mean specifically
the government but I I think that we can
turn that around we certainly have in
the past and it's my Ardent hope that we
can I also think that there's I'm not
deterministic but um there is something
about the demography which is going to
settle a lot of issues for us I think
myself and some people in the room will
not see that will will not live to see
it but we'll be gone and more people of
mixed race will um come into being in
this country and that will seem normal
to them and they will find other things
to disagree
about I mean as a professor at Santa
Cruz I've seen the future of California
and it is bright uh there's no question
about that look I I have one more
question for you and then we can we can
open it up um this is a terrible time to
lose our Collective memory preserving
Liberty equality and democracy and
protecting all of us from Universal
threats like anthropogenic climate
change and maybe nule nuclear
proliferation these require us to act
mindfully and quickly where should we
begin I mean does doesn't this room call
for call for Big
Ideas yeah I was going to say you first
no but um okay well actually this is um
it's a big idea it's not going to be
easy to um address but I honestly think
that the biggest problem um in our Civic
life in our public life is the role of
money and too much money and it's
infected politics I mean you know we
could talk about um income inequality I
think that's a reflection of the way
that we have distorted the role of money
in this country my understanding of
American history and I'm not an American
historian is that the founders wanted to
put into place Financial incentives
because they were so much against the
royalty and Aristocrats and the church
so copyright was not was something that
was to counter the Monopoly of um the
church and um you know royalty over
publishing so you know money kind of
inadvertently started to become this
linga franka and I think that um since
we don't seem to have an appropriate
amount of Shame about accumulating vast
amounts of money anymore that seem to
have gone by the way um that it's really
hard to regulate I also know that you
can make a lot of money in this country
without going into the most important
professions such as nurses firemen
teachers you know state senators that
kind of thing you know those are those
are those are loser professions in in
some people's measurement and it's just
how can people think of that so I mean I
don't know how we're going to change
that attitude but I think that that's if
we get at that then I think it's going
to begin to solve or at least unwind a
lot of the tightly wound things but it's
a gordian knot and I don't know how to
cut through it I don't have that sword
um your book is an excellent start and
uh and I commend it to all of you um I'd
love to open it up for uh questions um
yes you have the mic I have a mic is it
on there we go uh so my question is
about um staying present or the
importance of presence as we go through
time but I want to give you a quick
setup which is that I went to college as
a his of math and science guy got
pointed to A gtis Smith course of US
foreign policy from 1945 through the
present I became a history major and all
the classes I took were classes that
came up for the present um at that in
that course uh his last lecture he
thanked everyone for the course
evaluations because everyone complained
about there was too much material and he
said you know I've been teaching this
course since 1960 and there was 20 years
of material then and now there's 45
years of material so now it's going to
be a semester
course hearkening on your last question
I've been living through we've all been
living through predictions about 2050 in
climate change and we're now halfway
there since paying attention to at least
for me since 2000 so you know our our
our presence in time as we go forward
through things we're predicting or
seeing in the past is uh you know an
experience we have in life so I I wanted
you to expand a little bit on this this
how do we ride paying attention to the
present as a as something you brought up
that was important and how does that
evolve over time as we live through our
lives and and watch things unfold well
the present means something very
different for you know a six-year-old
than it does for someone who's 60 but I
think um in what I really mean is that
instead of thinking that somehow we're
going to solve this problem in the
future that hasn't gotten us very far um
and so and I want to impress that every
day whether we know it or not we're
making decisions that affect not just
our future our present and future but
other people's as well so I think to the
extent that you can widen um you know
your FOC your focus and see um how your
actions can ramify then I think that
staying in the present is a pretty good
thing I I don't think that you know the
the future it seems is always being
foreshortened and as you go through life
um it seems actually to get further and
further away it's paradoxical um and I
also think that there's way too much
emphasis um on in our consumer Society
on replacing things not investing in
things that um that last for a long time
as it was in the old days um and also
that we we pay too much attention give
too much Credence to this cry that oh
time is collapsing time is faster and
faster oh we're losing our attention
span no we're not losing our attention
span it hasn't changed at all there's a
lot more competing for it um and I don't
think we've yet learned how to filter
and control the things that are
competing for our attention but I I
think that's a unint a natural side
effect of all new media I mean if you
can go back and read the stuff that was
read about written about printing you
know it's just it's it'll make you cry
with laughter it's so funny so I I do
think that um and their lives were a lot
shorter than ours um that also changes
the perspective a lot I can't I I can't
possibly speak to the issue of why we
haven't done enough about climate change
but but that's not what this talk is
about uh thank you yes hi so if you look
at history I'm assuming that it's made
up of things that we believe are true
and these are like truth objects I call
them axiomatic truths is this is this
true are can we truly look at certain
things can we truly assemble a corpus of
axiomatic truths about how history
actually was and therefore will assemble
how where we're going and then see some
trajectory with that is that even
possible is that or is that even the way
to think about it no I I certainly don't
think axiomatic truth is part of History
um I and I certainly I mean I think
history is path dependent I mean there's
some things that are no longer possible
um because they've been decided before I
mean look at this that that River of
time I was showing um it's showing all
the things that feed into a river but
also all the things that feed out um I
think the chance and contingency Play
Hum humongous roles in human history and
in natural history and um any history of
the planet should show a history of the
universe should show how much chance has
played in contingency so to talk about
axiomatic law or rules and to talk about
the law of History I think is again it's
a category
mistake
yeah hi Abby hi hi um I really
appreciated how you talked about um
yearning for pushing past Grand
narratives and wanting to get into the
complexity and the richness of History
uh could you maybe spend some more time
on that perhaps Illuminating some
examples where not researchers and
academics but like the general
population like at a national level
actually engaged with events or history
like in that complex richness that we're
seeking I'm not sure what you're looking
for R.J but I will say that Anyone who
reads a really good biography will begin
to understand the complexity of a single
life if it's a good biography um you'll
be able to understand all the things
that all this the situation that a
person is born into is sort of given um
the constraints of their you know their
gender their family um mean the time
period they live in I mean I often think
about what it would have been like as a
woman to be born even a hundred years
before it's kind of
unimaginable um I don't like thinking
about it um but um but I do think that
biography is the clear the clearest
representation of complexity in history
and it's all in one it's in one book and
it's in a person who is made to be in
who is intrinsically interesting and a
good biographer will will reveal why it
is intrinsically interesting it doesn't
have to be a great person it could be
you know um there's some wonderful
biographies of um women in 17th century
New England based on their own Diaries
so you it can be a humble life but it
can show you well it can really tell you
how complicated things can be I think
public history the practice of public
history and community history also can
uh can help uh very sophisticated
engagement with historical thinking
there were some there's a question here
there's a question here and there's a
question
there um so you talked a bit about like
gaps and gaps in a history where things
are just missing but one thing I've
noticed um is there's also gaps where we
don't know how to interpret things
perfectly or less perfectly some of this
is literally just language that's the
easy example we don't know the language
but sometimes it's even for stuff like
just as
recent as like 100 years ago we might
not know the slang we might not know the
reference people when write when people
when are when they're writing stuff down
they assume so much context um and as a
historian who spends a lot of time with
work done by
archivists what is the kind of how do
you think we can be better at this for
future for the
future better at representing the
context you
mean better at um
represent better at including context
with the material so that it may be
interpreted from someone coming from so
far in the future that this context may
have deteriorated entirely yeah you know
I'm sorry to say that you actually can't
um one of the things that I mean you can
write a history book which has a lot of
context it will be very long but it will
be wonderful um but you know I have to
say as someone who studied medieval
Russian history you know there's
learning the language there's learning
about all the sources that were around
there's trying to get at the fact that
they didn't write about anything but
lurgical and Court Affairs you know you
can become conversent in a culture and
look at the gaps and be able to
interpret interpolate certain things but
never with any certainty so there's a
lot of sort of theorizing or a lot of I
should say
hypothesizing um but the past is really
gone and what's left is what's left I
have to say the greatest Boon to history
um in the past I'd say 50 years is the
advance in Material Science the fact
that there's so much about inert
material um entities you know soil and
things like that they can tell us so
much about the context in which Stone
Age people lived for example I mean you
can pick up any Journal um any issue of
science or nature and you'll see some
breakthrough they've been able to
analyze the DNA of certain soil and see
where the you know where the ruminants
were and in fact find a little smidge of
DNA from somebody in in Asia but
actually this is in Scotland how did
they ever get there so I mean in that
sense it's constantly expanding but it's
at a scale which isn't exactly what I'm
think you're looking
for let's take two more questions
um this is a question maybe for both of
you um if you take the broadest strokes
and looking at even Material Science and
our current technology which makes
multiple copies of most things would you
say that on average that the percentage
of things being AR archived is shrinking
or is it enlarging over time other words
are are we headed towards where fewer
and fewer percent of everything made is
being archived or are we generally
headed towards a a world where more and
more of the world is actually being
archived um I'll I'll take that first um
first of all there's just an incal
incalculable amount more being inscribed
to begin with to being recorded so um in
that sense it'll always be bigger as to
how much of that I mean the present is
just creating way more information than
ever before a sort of promiscuous amount
as to how long it is going to be
preserved I think that depends upon how
well we how good we are at preserving
digital
information
perent what percentage of everything
being
made we we'll survive I'm sorry but
we'll we'll survive oh I mean obviously
there's the more is being produced the
more that's going to be captured at
least in the short term the
percent growing or sh so capturing so I
think I see a distinction here capturing
being fixated in some form or another um
that isn't archiving uh that just means
that it's been captured so I take a
picture of Abby with my phone uh it's
probably not going to outlast uh my
phone or it won't Outlast Google so I
think uh never has so much been captured
never will so little be
archived it's a good one that's a quote
there um yeah I wish I'd said that I
will I will I will quote you on that
yeah thank you so much for your job yeah
last question do you have any
recommendations for practices that we
can adopt into our lives to help build a
sense of shared reality with people
around us uh yeah well I'd say the first
thing is um find some people you know
whom you respect but really disagree
with and get to know them and talk with
them and that be I mean you know you
want to have somebody that you can
respect because you want to be able to
confide you don't want to feel afraid of
having a conversation with them you
don't want to feel censored by them or
judged by them um but you also have to
listen to them as closely as you expect
them to listen to you and so if you can
somehow you don't have to reconcile your
views but if you both understand what's
at stake um in your views why you arrive
at the at the views you have then you
will literally have a shared sense of
reality you will um you may not agree
but you will at least um at least get
beyond the that's ridiculous how can you
possibly believe that you know you'll
understand thank you Abby for everything
let's let's have a hand for Abby Smith
Ramsey thank
you and um I think we'll have a a little
bit of housekeeping here and then we'll
uh lift a glass and maybe buy a
book yes thank you everyone we're going
to reset the room back to a bar so if
you stand up and grab your drink we'll
uh work on getting all the seats but um
you're welcome to stay aby's book is
available um in the back of the room and
she'll be around for ation and
[Music]
signing